foreign
student loans are emerging from Deep
Freeze and borrowers are confused
The Wall Street Journal says I will add
to that
um they're angry oh yeah I will add to
that that they're scared yes
frustrated yeah it's a student loan
borrowers are finding out that
restarting 1.6 trillion Federal program
is much more confusing than just when
they're able to turn the switch off
right it's harder to turn it back on
with the pandemic relief ending
borrowers will start owing interest as
of Friday as in in four days they are
learning new payment schedules they're
often getting this information via email
from these servicers that they might not
have ever heard of okay uh and this is
what I want to talk about I know you
guys are getting
emails in and it's like oh who are you
oh you're the person who's cervix in my
loan now and you don't even know you
don't even know what your payment is it
says it's this is about four in ten
borrowers their loan was transferred to
a new servicer during the pause that
began March 20 2020. 40 percent
they moved the servicing on an already
incompetent and inept industry yeah
this is going to be a freaking
barrel of Fish Hooks
you could have multiple new Surfacers I
mean you got 40 million people
so 40 is 16 million
16 million accounts have been moved and
are all restarting interest Friday and
payments in October
and only the government can create a
mess like this you mean you have to work
to screw up Christmas seriously look
and the problem is these people are
calling to find out information this one
lady her story is she's had her loans
forever she's got 14 000 left and she's
calling and not able to get through the
lines because the lines are so jammed
and she can't get clarification on what
her loan is on what the amount is and so
after three years of payment she's
finally called of no payment she's
finally called and can't get answers so
that's what we've been telling you guys
don't wait on this don't sit on your
hands don't wait till the last minute
you need to here's what's going to
happen if you do nothing because you get
confused because you can't get through
on the lines they're going to tag you
with late fees because you're not paying
your payment on time even though you
don't even know where they are
yeah they're gonna you're gonna get
confused because there's a couple of
things there's different options out
there right they've got these payment
plans that they're automatically
enrolling some people in and they will
automatically enroll you if you are
delinquent on your first few payments so
you do not want to just act like this is
not happening right now it's time to be
in denial now they'll put you in the
30-year you're never going to pay it off
plan
automatically that's the default plan
yeah 30 years you're never going to pay
it off
like a mortgage you're going to keep
forever that's the idea the other
default is that it's it's like they're
calling it an on-ramp Dave where it's I
need a 12 month on-ramp during which
time by the way interest is accumulating
but they're telling you okay that's fine
we just won't report
you yeah we just won't report it you're
still screwing yourself we just won't
tell anybody we're going to screw you
but we're going to ease you into it so
let me help you with this okay A Bank
that has a loan out
with you
if they are collecting the interest does
not want you to pay off the loan
they want to collect the interest
forever you know what a student loan
servicer is
a bank
you know when they want you to pay off
the student loan never
they just want you to pay fees and
interest
forever so they're going to make this
difficult and confusing and frustrating
because they want you there
forever and they're going to offer you
plans that are forever
this is how this works boys and girls
don't be naive this is this is called
Planned incompetence
the navient a the navient agent on
borrowed future said that they were
trained to mess up the call so you would
hang up and get frustrated and not get
your situation rectified so you stayed
in debt
forever that's in our documentary on
student loans a an actual agent that
used to be on the phones with navient
and uh we we had to garble her voice
because she feared for her life because
you know you don't cross these people
I'm kidding but not really but um oh my
gosh well here's what ever what I want
you guys to take away from this is a
we're here to give you information and
we're going to tell you more about a
live stream that we're going to offer
about this very thing but y'all are
smart you can go online you can read
about this stuff you can find out for
yourself you can be in the know so that
when you talk to these people on the
phone they're not you're not relying on
them for information you already know
what you want to do and you're going to
do what you're gonna do that does that
make sense don't call these people
saying well what do you think I should
do do you think I should get on a
payment plan and forget my lounge honey
that ship has sailed they are not your
advisors yeah we're talking about the uh
the Supreme Court shot a cannonball
through his butt okay there is no
forgiveness no we're done he sunk the
ship it's done the ship has sailed it's
gone yeah you're not getting forgiveness
the forgiveness is going to come at the
tips of your fingers when you push
submit payments submit payment submit
payment over and over and over and you
pay the freaking thing off that's where
forgiveness is going to come from so I
you don't need to ask anybody about that
that's already pretty much old news it
was called a it was called a suspect a
sus move politically when he when he
said the Forgiveness anyway he's a
lawyer he knew an executive order didn't
have the ability to do something that
the act of Congress is required and the
Supreme Court confirmed it for him it
was sus from beginning it helped him
with the midterm elections guys grow up
pay off your freaking debts those of you
that have had head in the sand let me
tell you about this this stuff has a
high rate of Resurrection it will come
up out of the Grave zombie fire your
butt okay it will come up and walk dead
straight into your living room deal with
this that that's a fact I told people I
was sharing with them a couple days back
on the show you know Sam and I had 280
000 of student loans different providers
they got sold off and were spread into
chunks everywhere did you experience the
planned and competence oh yeah uh look
if you that's why I said if you get on
the phone with these people these are
their parents are first yes they hire
people whose parents are coached the
worst yeah kissing cousins the worst of
the worst okay you can't depend on them
they will keep you in debt forever your
inbred brain damaged fool get my account
straightened out oh my God yeah it's
unbelievable all they want is a payment
all they want is a payment they don't
want your piece and we actually they
don't really want a payment they just
want the interest and the fees they want
you to stay in debt forever did I
mention that forever there we go so
we're gonna help you with this
Wall Street journals telling you that
people are really confused we've added
to that we know some of you are angry
and we know some of you are scared
you're disillusioned with the political
system welcome to adulthood and so uh
yeah there you go you're gonna end up
paying this boys and girls men and women
gentlemen ladies you're going to pay it
so let us help you we're going to do
that we're gonna Jade who knows
something about paying this off paid off
260 000 bucks Rachel Cruz leading
student loan expert Financial uh expert
with Ramsey and I'm going to hang around
too the three of us are going to do a
student loan live stream we're excited
about this it's going to be incredible
it's how we got into this mess and how
we're going to get out student loan debt
in America we're doing this on September
the 12th you know how much we're going
to charge you nothing it's free for free
and let me just reiterate it's worth
every penny this is we're gonna give you
real solutions we're going to show you
tactful things
look at that look at that we're going to
help you guys yeah seriously we're going
to show you uh how to get out but
uh you know
spoiler alert
no easy way there's work involved yeah
this is not alert you're gonna pay a
price to win spoiler alert we don't have
any hacks that make this easy spoiler
alert all we're going to do is do our
best to give you information and
inspiration to get your butt in gear
because some of you have been sitting
around your head in the sand and it's
not going to get any better you know
what happens when you stick your head in
the sand your butt is exposed okay it
doesn't work all right you've got to
deal with this you got to deal with it
student loan live stream
ramseysolutions.com student loans sign
up it's September the 12th it's
completely free and uh we want you to
watch it